this past weekend
[Music]
what's up guys Merry Christmas it is
December 25th in the year 2017 and this
is this is that this is that Christmas
time you know some places they don't
even have Christmas when you think about
it some hell good luck in hell dude
maybe you get Easter some other places
they probably don't have it deep in
space underwater
people in a coma so I think it's that
time of year when I want to thank you
know that I'm pretty fortunate to have a
holiday like this where you can get
together with others and even get
together with yourself crack in or a
little bit of yourself you know
something you got to twist that top off
yourself and see if you spoiled or not
and that's what I think this time is
here Christmas time you know a time to
really just check in with yourself ask
your heart if it's still working because
you still got a lot of a lot of time to
kill out here in the universe merry
Christmas to you guys I am currently in
Natchez Mississippi and I just had a
little bit of prime rib so if you if I
sound you know like I got other animals
bodies in me that's because I've had
some prime rib and that [ __ ] was rare
you know I was at a house party with
some family friends and sometime you get
in that meat line and you know it's not
it wasn't like a buffet where you get
there and you get to pick your meat cuz
if I pick my own meat yeah I get a meat
I want but sometimes when you're just
cruising along in the meat line and you
get up there it means that you're gonna
get you get what meat you get you know
you get what meat you get and I got a
piece of rare rare meat I mean this
thing halfway through it I thought you
know I could have been a veterinarian I
wasn't sure you know what side of the UH
what's out of the realm I was doing was
living on if I was dining or if I was
you know maybe in the fourth year of
some type of veterinarian school where
you actually get to slice into the
animals because I had some rare meat but
I'm out here in Natchez Mississippi and
I'm coming to you today from sharp sound
design studios here I got a nephew
that's in this band called Bishop gun
and I'll put some of their hits on as we
get into the next year but he has a
studio here in Natchez Mississippi down
here on the water and it's a really
beautiful spot and so I'm just fortunate
to be here I had to crack into here
because the place I'm staying that
doesn't have internet you know they
don't have the World Wide Web if not
every place does it's like a little it's
almost like a little Ethiopia out here
in Mississippi and they don't have it
and try to drive here into town and we
got into this studio and it's pretty
cool to be here and to be here with you
guys today I want to thank everybody for
a wonderful year you know I want to
thank our charter sponsor gray block
pizza you know and if you got if if
sometime if you feel your tongue around
in your mouth and you feel a lot of
extra space in your mouth then maybe
what you need is a little bit of pie a
little bit of pizza pie some Italian
style maybe you need to fill your jowls
with that modern our own crust and queso
you know you need to get that pizza you
need to get that hit up and you can do
that at grey block pizza dot-com you
know I've had a wonderful experience so
far here on Christmas I got to spend
time with my family I you know it's
Christmas Eve
right now technically you know so some
of you guys will hear this on Christmas
Day and I got to spend we did Christmas
at my family's house yesterday and my
sister lives out there in Santa Molly we
see Anna and it's a good place to get
you know medium medium ly educated a
good place to meet an animal if you have
a woman to get to know an animal on a
first-name basis yes I spent some time
at her house and they had two bunnies
one of them is a show bunny and one of
them is just uh you know a bunny that's
not really trying to be a model or
trying to be fancy it and it actually
had some congestion and I put a picture
of it on my Instagram it had one of the
bunnies was dealing some congestion but
it was nice to be around our animals and
just around family and we had a really
nice time out
had some donuts my stepfather was out
there and he was in a war and so he
talks about that a lot of bit cuz he
gots dementia and it's pretty well when
dementia gets into your brain dementia
is basically a it's like the enemy in
dementia is like dementia is like you
know that kid in school that didn't
study didn't do any homework never knew
what the [ __ ] was going on never had any
books never had any pencils you know
never washed his hair sometime had body
lice that sort of stuff that's kind of
like what dementia is and that person
starts living inside of your head and
you slowly start to become that person
when you're a senior citizen and that's
something that my stepdad was going
through and he was you know talking a
lot about being in the war and stuff
like that but the best you can do
usually if somebody has that is you know
hold their hand or you know talk to them
about the war a little bit maybe give
them some doughnuts you know you can
offer to give them beer but don't give
them beer or liquor but don't even give
them liquor so we had a nice time over
there and then I came up into
Mississippi today I got some other
family up here and I used to work on a
farm up here when I was younger I used
to work on a soybean in corn and cotton
farm and we and my buddy of mine a good
friend of mine who who who I worked on
his farm he passed away years ago but he
has a couple of children up here and and
I come up here in Christmas Eve and we
spend time together so we had a really
you know just a nice time went to church
today went to at 3 o'clock mass I didn't
know they had that you know that
afternoon Mass it's kind of like the
same time like if you ever been in the
grocery store at midnight it's kind of
the same type of clientele you know a
lot of risque sisters and you know a lot
of a lot of trouble brothers and risque
sisters in there you know looking for
the Lord because you know something's
going on if you come looking for the
Lord in the afternoon well we had a nice
time at the church today so that was
pretty beautiful and you know just
getting to just feel feel the joy of
being around other people you know and
that's one of the things that I was just
reminded of is just to just quit
thinking sometimes and just be just be
where I am
you know when I get that urge to go look
at my phone just to let that urge go and
just instead just reach out and you know
touch somebody that's close to me as
long as I know them and as long as
legally I'm able to touch them and
that's just what I'm trying to do it's
what I'm gonna try to do tomorrow and
and a little bit more this Christmas
holidays it's just slow it down you know
hit that slow button hit that pause and
get that and and it's been a good year
and I you know and I thank you guys so
much I think all my patreon errs I'm
gonna put a video up later on uh on
YouTube only of the time I spent with my
family so you guys will be able to check
in and get to meet a little bit of them
it was hard to record because it's so
loud in there especially with animals
and people interacting because animals
don't know that it's Christmas you know
sometimes you see an animal and you're
like oh yeah that animal knows that it's
you know Halloween or that animal knows
that it's leap year but if you think
that that's honestly and not to you know
throw stones at you but that's [ __ ]
that's crazy and and it was just you
know when you got a lot of people
dementia and you got animals and you got
a lot of children running around
it's joyous but it's a tough time new to
record something where you can hear
everybody artfully and good but I'll do
what I can with that video and put it up
on YouTube later on Christmas Day Oh
what else you know I had a pheasant
earlier for dinner next to that prime
rib I had a little bit of a pheasant and
man this thing the meat is so small on a
pheasant almost and I just seen that
movie downsized downsizing last night
with Matt Damon and I'll talk about that
in a minute but this pheasant seemed
like you know if you ever had a pheasant
you feel I don't want to say you feel
like a pervert but you know you almost
want to check the you know like you
almost want to get consent from its
parents before you even eat it because
that thing it comes in a little you feel
like you shouldn't really be getting to
know it as well as you're getting to
know it if you ever had a pheasant so
that was
that was tough to get through it was
tough to get through as a young man you
know especially these days where you
don't even know how you can talk to a
you know someone of the other you know
how you're gonna relate to the opposite
sex and you know you just want to be
careful in these days and tread softly
it was a little you know I felt a little
risque eating that pheasant you know and
I felt almost at one point like I should
put a little prophylactic on my tongue
you know because it's just I don't know
if you haven't had one you don't know
what I'm talking about if you have had
one then you're right here with me that
they should put something you know what
in the future I would like to know that
these pheasants are you know at least 19
20 years old at least are 25 or 30 years
old so if I eat them in the future I'm
going to try and do a little bit more
background history a background search
on some of these you know novice Birds
and I'm putting into my gullet I'm
putting on putting into my face
especially here you know uh on Jesus
birthday so that's it
you know it's I'm not gonna do a long
cast today guys and it's it's because
it's you know it's your Christmas too
and it's you know we're out here
together and you know I'm trying not to
have one thing about Christmas sometimes
I get so many texts and and I feel
responsible to give out so many texts
and that just becomes and you can spend
half your day on your phone just respond
in two people and reply in two people
it's almost like you don't even get to
enjoy you know the essence of the piece
that's presented to us sometimes at this
time of year so I'm gonna try to do that
a little bit more over these next couple
of days and especially on tomorrow
I saw that movie downsizing the first 38
minutes of it phenomenal I'm a big Matt
Damon fan in the first 38 minutes of
that film man it will make you want to
just
it'll make you pet your own eyebrows now
[ __ ] is just straight Joe into your face
but after that it got real ambitious and
it turned into this
climate change but on I guess on you
know how we live in the world and
poverty and you know it had some great
ideas but it was just way too much it
was supposed to just be like a fun movie
about getting small and suddenly it was
this heavy movie that was very confusing
and so if you're you know planning to go
see it I would wait I'd wait till it
comes out on something that's a little
more easily to view it on and then I
would split that cost with somebody else
who's curious about it or just watch the
first 38 minutes and make up your own
ending that's what we did we went to the
film and we saw it there and then we
kind of decided to think about how would
we you know view the film differently or
how would we you know what a new ending
that we would come up with so I wouldn't
recommend it
but I don't think it's a bad movie I
just you know is the only movie that
I've walked out of and and one of the
thing was I was about to walk out and
then some other people walked out and to
me those people in my mind you know
being judgmental I was like those people
look dumb and if they're dumb and
they're walking out then then I felt
dumb for staying you know I felt even
dumber so I mean that just shows you
where my head was at anyway
just sitting there you know stuck in
judgment and stuck in weird [ __ ] in the
middle of the night in the movie theater
but I'm glad I wasn't spraying out in
there I'm glad I wasn't doing nothing
perverse you know I one time man I met a
damn you know I I made some poor choices
in some of these theaters but you know
but that's that's the past and we're
moving onward but I uh I want to thank
you guys for just being a part of the
podcast this year I want to wish
everybody a Merry Christmas and I hope
that you you know if you feel a moment
in your heart today or tomorrow or this
week during the holidays to reach out to
somebody or to reach across the room and
hug somebody extra or to [ __ ] shake a
little [ __ ] in the neck a little
you know or to just take somebody's
pulse sometimes that's the most sexy
thing you can do is just walk up to
somebody
family member a loved one even a child
that's healthy you know and that's not
that you don't have any interest in and
just take take their pulse you know just
put your hand on that artery and just
feel their life in them you know get
that hitter right off they neck and
that's free just let you just remind
yourself which you're on earth with
other humans other people out here
living life and doing things because
that's what it is man I feel like in the
end you know when it comes down to it
and they've written they roll you down
into that hole or they you know a couple
people you know throw you out no hole or
whatever the how every whatever burial
you're gonna get that you probably are
reaching up wishing you had enough woman
or just one last touch you know somebody
sings a song I think it's just called
I'm just looking for some touch and it's
you know I really think that's what
we're all looking for so I wish that
everybody has a wonderful holiday I wish
you keep your heart open keep your head
open and touch somebody take somebody's
pulse touch somebody's neck if you if
you are touch somebody's nuts a crotch
if you with them like that
if you have that connection you know be
a part of somebody's life you know just
get it out of your body if you got to
get something out of your body you got
to get that feeling a joy out of you
legally get it out of you because this
the time of year to do it
that's that last week of the year this
had run up to the new year this thought
this is the finish line so finish this
thing strong solid finish this thing
which are heart open you know finish
this thing popping off setting off and
we you know getting up early to jerk off
or don't be you know doing a bunch of
pills or popping percocets out there
take care of yourself love somebody that
needs to be loved love yourself that's
what I'm gonna try to do because man we
all struggle and I'm not preaching at
you but I'm preaching with you you know
I'm trying to be here in your corner and
this Christmas man you know and if I do
see a kid loving that Christmas boy make
it even more lovable form
you know put a little chocolate on you
know put a little chocolate on
somebody's neck or back when I was young
and you know we didn't have a lot of
money my mother would put chocolate on
us just like on our shoulders and the
big thing was to try to lick the
chocolate off of each other's shoulders
when we were children and it was like a
free game that we could play it only
cost my mother about a dollar 50 to get
that bottle of chocolate sauce and we'd
get all you know we just get them
chocolate shoulders going on and just
running around and trying to lick each
other's shoulders you know we were all
family most of us except sometimes some
neighbor kids but we were close enough
or there wasn't nothing wrong about it
and we were just enjoying each other's
company so you know it's nice to have
those memories and share those memories
with your loved ones if you ever had
something special happen during the
holidays share with a loved one
don't keep just don't keep it inside if
you got something pretty sitting inside
you let that bird out and let that bird
land in somebody else's cage for a
little bit that's all you got to do to
let it loose I promise you that thing al
and whatever that bird is a story a
moment a feeling a memory a touch a
promise an apology let that bird out let
that bird land somewhere I promise you
it will all right man thank you guys for
being with me on this Christmas merry
Christmas to you
Happy Hanukkah to you happy holidays
happy everything whatever you like or
furia if you're agnostic your atheist
look and you want to be out there
freestyling go on get out there but I'll
see you on the other side man or I won't
you know but if I get to that other side
and we'll send you a little message you
know something naughty you know I might
put a little bit of a thumbtack in you
in your ec cup or something wild like
that to let you know that I'm out there
because I'm going on man you know I'm
not staying here I'm not staying here
I'm not staying here stagnant I'm going
on when I go I'm going on onward all
right man Merry Christmas be good to
yourselves you probably deserve it and I
will I'll see you guys next episode
thank you so much I also have to get in
this add one more time we have
for live tree live tree you can check it
out
if you're tired of watching films like I
saw downsizing they're no good we can
change it the future of films is in the
hands of the consumer you pick who's in
it you pick who directs it you pick what
happens to it it's the fantasy football
of film work and it's all starting at
live tree comm check it out now see what
they're doing see what's going on see
what the future can look like and how
you can be a part of it with that add
with that add out of the way thank you
guys so much for your support and and I
love you man I'm trying to anyway [ __ ] I
don't know what sometimes I don't know
what I'm trying to do but I am I am
trying and I'm not gonna stop that part
of it all right be good brother this
past weekend